(upbeat guitar strumming)
- [Narrator] Dead Kevin.
- [Ryan] So she picked me up
and we walked out of the bar.
She was that strong.
- Like in that movie?
- She was huge, yeah.
- Oh, hey!
- Hey!
- Look at this little guy.
- It's a dog.
- Yeah, I'd be careful guys.
He might have fleas.
- Oh, come on, he's cute.
Look at him.
- He's homeless.
- Looks like a street dog to me.
(dog whimpers)
- Well, yeah, that's why
he needs a home.
Come on, buddy.
- Want a home, little guy?
- [Ahmed] Come home with us?
Wanna come home with us?
- Come on.
- Come on, come on.
(laughing)
- Aw, look at him.
- Hey, hey, hey, hey buddy!
- (laughing) Hi.
- Hey, hey.
- We can call you Pumpkin.
- Pumpkin?
- He's definitely a Dave.
- He's not a Pumpkin!
- Yeah, he's a Pumpkin.
- He looks like a Dave.
- Dave?
- Yeah.
- No.
- Let's call him Gladiator.
- No, he's too sweet
to be a Gladiator.
- Gladiator.
- Let's give him
some space, guys.
- How about Max?
- Max!
- [Ryan and Ahmed] Max!
Max.
Come here.
Lay with me.
Hey, buddy.
Hey, hey, come on.
Max, Max!
- Max! Look at me!
Look into my eyes.
Look at my eyes.
Okay?
Sit.
You sit!
(plastic bag rustling)
(dog whimpering)
- She said it was a break,
but it feels more
like a break up.
She never responds to my texts.
- Ready?
Go get them!
(dog barking)
(screaming)
Oh shit!
- I don't have anything to
give you or anything, so...
- Yeah, I love this!
I love you!
(dog barking)
Oh no!
- And it's like,
what is she doing?
I don't know what she's
doing, but we used to--
(dog barking)
- Good boy!
Ow! Fuck that!
It's so bad, it's so good!
(dog barking)
Good boy! Ow!
- Here.
Go eat this.
(dog panting)
- We're going to have a nice
long, happy life together, Max.
- I always wanted a dog.
(doorbell ringing)
- Hi, sorry to bother you.
I'm looking for my dog.
He's a small--
(dog barking)
Oh my god!
(dog whimpering)
That's my baby.
Oh yeah.
Why do you have my dog?
- We thought he was homeless.
- No, he's wearing a collar.
- Oh, we thought it was
a street dog necklace.
- It's not okay.
- No.
No, in retrospect,
we're, that's not.
We're not okay.
- [Woman] It's not.
- We are sorry.
- Yeah, I mean, we'll keep him.
If you want us to keep him--
- We taught him well, I think.
- Come on, Dave.
Let's go, come on.
- [Jack] Oh, I'm sorry, did
you say his name was Dave?
Did you just hear that?
- Remember what I taught you.
(guitar strumming)
- From the majestic Pyrenees
to the Nova Scotian
mountain snap warbler,
dogs have been man's best friend
since the beginning of time.
Tell us about your favorite
pet in the comments section
and subscribe to our YouTube
channel, DeadKevinSketch.
- Subscribe!
(snapping)
(hissing)